sur les traces de léonard de vinci 7 en
bois en indre-et-loire que l'artiste de
génie aux multiples talents a passé les
trois dernières années de sa ville
occupée sur l'invitation de françois 1er
le château du clos lucé château que l'on
vous invite à découvrir françois privat
stéphane alejandro la résidence d'un
génie pour une photo souvenir
le château du clos lucé à amboise a eu
pour locataires prestigieux léonard de
vinci
c'est ici que le maître acheva son
saint-jean-baptiste ou encore la célèbre
joconde
mais aujourd'hui à la place de l'atelier
un salon et dans sa chambre et en
plusieurs endroits du bâtiment
on a découvert des restes de fresques on
peut imaginer cette chambre la
chandeleur ainsi entièrement recouvertes
de fresques
or ces frais sont bien sûr attribué à
l'école de léonard ses disciples il
vient au clos lucé en 15/100 16 avec
accompagné probablement d'une quinzaine
une vingtaine d'élèves les machines
extraordinaires de léonard comme on
l'appelle familièrement ici ont pris
possession du sous sol du château un
système mécanique complexe propulser
cette première voiture également un char
d'assaut une mitrailleuse à directions
multiples et de nombreuses machines de
guerre c'est génial ce que je vois ici
non
son tir la prospère quand il a vécu je
connaissais davantage pour pour ses
oeuvres picturales la peinture que pour
ses créations et ses réalisations en
terme d'art de la guerre toujours au
sous sol une voûte intrigante l'entrée
d'un mystérieux souterrain au fond de
cette galerie début d'un souterrain
probablement le souterrain permettant
ainsi à françois 1er de se rencontrer
car nous sommes distant de peu près 3
400 300 mètres du château d'amboise
avant de quitter le clos lucé à détour
par le parc des reproductions à
l'échelle 1 des machines extraordinaires
permettent de faire rêver les enfants